Here's all the food I made my husband for
Super Bowl Sunday.
I started off by making myself a blueberry
thyme mocktail,
and then I pickled some green cabbage.
So I sliced it really finely with my mandolin,
added some jalapenos,
and then topped it with my vinegar mixture.
I had my dough rising for a couple hours.
Since I was making some burger buns,
I cut those up
and then form those into little balls
and let those rise for another one to two hours
just until they were soft.
In the meantime,
I got started on making some pretzel bites.
Absolutely loves pretzel bites,
so I knew that these had to be on the menu for tonight.
So I made the dough,
covered that until the gluten relaxed
for about 15 to 30 minutes,
then I rolled it into little ropes,
cut my little bites,
and then they went into my water with some baking soda.
After 10 to 15 seconds,
I popped them on the baking sheet,
sprinkle them with salt,
and then bake them until they were golden brown.
When it was time to bake my little brioche burger buns,
I topped them with my egg wash and some sesame seeds,
and once they were all baked,
I let them cool completely,
and then I moved on to my chicken wings.
I covered them in seasoning
and then pop them in the oven for about an hour
while I made a little side salad.
I wanted Something refreshing
to cut through all my other flavors.
So I decided to make a blood orange fennel salad
with a mustard vinaigrette.
I set that aside while I started on my patties.
I wanted to keep them simple,
so I made a cilantro cumin Patty
with some caramelized onion cheddar on top.
I cut my buns in half,
put the Patty on top,
and assembled my burger
with some arugula,
pickled cabbage.
And you cannot forget crispy onions.
And I dust my wings
and my buffalo sauce. I made,
added some parsley.
Also made a white cheddar sauce for my pretzel bites.
And this bread was gone in an hour and a half.